[Music]
welcome to cunnilingus class I'm Sabu's
Mike I'll steer a songster we're here to
teach y'all how to go down on [ __ ]
right now [ __ ] ain't being satisfied
so check quick get on that clitoris so
damn hard I just don't like that
nonsense that's like putting the tip yo
penis in the vacuum y'all need to chill
on the clitoris go around that business
that's like a button made of a million
penis tops now every [ __ ] like her
cunnilingus a little bit difficult Ana's
unlike snowflakes snowflakes is
different learn your bitch's snowflake
ask your [ __ ] what she wants Ben do
what she say some [ __ ] like it in a
circle some [ __ ] like it up and down
[ __ ] like it hard [ __ ] like it
soft communicate with your [ __ ] make
the hell the bet what you tell them hey
B C D I'm gonna grab your hand like
she'll pull your damn head off
sit with that let her talk about be a
little DDD a little bit of dee dee dee
dee dee vaginas deserve respect you
don't want someone slapping around your
little homey you have yo how you like
your BJ's damn dawg all the time shut up
that's cause penises is easy
everytime this is hard there's an
explosion at the envelope Factory raps
everywhere a world plans you need to
lick away out the factory but every
bitch's flaps is different on your
bitch's particular flaps that's be crazy
every flap need to be listened to and
then you will get on the factory alas
stay down there LAN you're breathing
like your swimming gotta be talking
about stroke stroke breathe stroke
stroke breathe alright let's take a
five-minute break
when we come back we're gonna talk about
warming your [ __ ] up before you get
busy and that'll last for more than two
damn minutes take a peach and practice
actor so if you take a picture practice
take a picture practice
oh I think it's gonna work 30 down 3
billion to go
[Laughter]
[Music]
spread the meat
[Music]
[Applause]
you fools get four hilarious though
do any of that actually get in your
mouth
[Music]